congratulations how do you feel you have
achieved the task of taking on batman
for the first time
it's so surreal i mean it's like it
literally i i was just texting somebody
early and saying i'm going to the batman
premiere tonight and they're like you
know i find it really weird that you're
a batman i'm like yeah that's really
really weird and this is the first time
i'm seeing it with them with an audience
no way yeah you kind of freaked out
about that
nervous kind of i mean i i've i've
i've had enough people telling me they
like it so i'm kind of i'm i'm i'm
hoping it'll go it'll go well but yeah
as we say here it ain't your first rodeo
rob you've been a part of a big
franchise before in the past so
i have been yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's been a while though it's been it's
been a while since you have like people
really really hyped like this so like
you know
welcome back to the circus but what kind
of look we've seen batman so many times
before different adaptations what
classic batman's did you look to to say
oh this has been done maybe this is how
i'm going to bring in this is my
approach to this iconic character
uh i mean i the script was really really
solid and um and then i kind of knew how
to do i thought i had an idea of how to
do this from the script but i just
started reading
tons of the graphic novels and i didn't
really grow up on comics and i kind of
realized that there was just a feeling
that they just
even though they kind of changed through
genres and tone
there's a specific batman feeling that
really started to connect to me and i
you know just quite organic i wasn't
particularly thinking like oh this is
how i want to do it it's just kind of
what came out but did you ever connect
too deep to the source because he's
moodier he's darker this time around
yeah it's definitely pretty moody and
also i mean luckily there was no one to
talk to the whole time i was shooting
this movie so i could kind of just
basically stay in character at the
entire time is it true that you wore
george clooney's batman suit for your
audition yes how did that help you get
into the world how does it feel
it's a little tight
uh body shape now oh my gosh finally i i
hear that you were roommates with andrew
garfield jamie dornan and eddie rayman
eddie raymond and charlie cox so what
was the living situation like on that
front you've all now almost all played
superheroes so are you comparing notes
now
it's very strange
i mean i wasn't actually rumors they
were all kind of they were all roommates
and i was like oh it's the last one
invite i was like always invited as an
afterthought i'd be like there'd be like
one slice of pizza left and i'd be like
it's like
it's really for me
i love it well you've earned your slice
of pizza after this film sir more to
come right a couple more hopefully yeah
yeah
hopefully it's a done deal buddy
enjoy tonight